I think the remarkable personal and
ideological journey of Sandra Day
O'Connor was to me the core of the book
and the most interesting part of it I
guess what you saw was a traditional
Goldwater moderate Republican confronted
by the Bush administration which she of
course helped bring into office in Bush
v Gore and you watched her saying wait a
second this is not my Republican Party
this is too extreme and then you have
the Terri Schiavo case where O'Connor
sees her Republican Party sort of
starting to invade the most personal
parts of of medical decision-making at a
time when her own husband is slipping
into the grip of a similar condition
Alzheimer's disease that personal
political drama was really the biggest
surprised and the most interesting
you